Cheer up, Grumpy Cat!
You're gonna be in a movie.
Hey, I'm Jillian on Buzz60.
For someone so cantankerous, Grumpy Cat is doing pretty well for herself.
Grumpy Cat, who's real name is Tardar Sauce, will play herself in a movie...
...where not unlike Garfield, she'll be able to talk.
Deadline reports that Broken Road Productions is behind the feature film.
You know, the guys who brought us the Zookeeper and Jack and Jill.
Come on, it's a movie about a talking cat.
I know she's super famous, but who are you expecting? Scorsese?
But seriously, Grumpy Cat has a huge fanbase.
20 million Youtube views, close to one million fans on Facebook,...
...lots of TV appearances under her belt,...
...and she was voted meme of the year at the 2013 Webby Awards.
And this won't be her first time in a leading role.
Grumpy cat is the face of Friskies Cat Food.
Still, with all this success, Grumpy Cat is still as grouchy as ever.
Well, I guess she learned from her celebrity doppelganger.
That is just uncanny.
Buzz60, now you know, pass it on.